have you seen anything even remotely
like that happen
no no no no no no no no
no no no no no like that could never
happen i have been notified that there
is a new medical drama
called nurses i needed a nurse to help
me understand
what's going on the show welcome back
bianca and tysara
to the channel thank you so much for
having me i am an er travel nurse i
specialize in
trauma i believe this this show kind of
highlights er nurses so i feel like i'll
have like a really good insight on to
what we're about to see here
can you take my photo that is so
you i feel like you would take a selfie
you would ask a patient with an iv
pole to take a selfie i can tell she was
new too because like when she's walking
in
she's like oh my god like here's the
hospital and it's just
listen up i'm your charge nurse damian
but you can call me sir
or sir damien or damian sir for those
who don't know can you tell us what a
charged nurse's duties are yeah so
charge is basically kind of like what
you would assume a manager is in most
roles that are like outside of medicine
the charge nurse is basically going to
say who goes where into what unit and
who's assigned to what things if you
have an issue
your first line of defense is going to
be your charge nurse to try to rectify
the issue or if you happen to need
backup on a situation
you're going to want to talk to your
charge nurse so not only do they handle
like the managerial side of it but they
also assist you clinically as well
i want you to know who you are and what
you are
because when your elbow deep in a 75
year old man who's cursed with anal
boils
or checking the lady business of a
half-dilated laboring woman is bellowing
like a gorilla
he won't be a rock star you'll be the
one thing between that old guy and the
death of his dignity i love that she
said that actually right there um
because one of the things that you're
gonna realize very early on
especially being a nursing student or
like a fresh new
graduate nurse is you have to maintain
dignity and there's dignity and things
that most people would look
kind of down upon but you have to
remember that everybody that you're
dealing with is a human being with a
whole history and a whole life and
emotions and everything
and if you put yourself into those
situations um especially medically
speaking
you never want somebody to be scared to
talk to you about an issue because
they're embarrassed
or you know they just don't want to be
seen in that light someone who's
vulnerable
is opening up to you allowing you to see
them in this vulnerable light
that's that that should be something
that's appreciated and
i feel like nurses at least the ones
i've worked with
have been the ones that get so much
positivity from those moments
someone might say i don't want to help
someone i'm tired like this but a nurse
will say i'll go help and then
reap the mental health benefit from
helping that person all right
listen up as you've no doubt seen ivan's
just driven into a courtyard of people
down at the art college
so not the kind of day that anyone
expected would rise up
lives depend on it whatever comes
through that door
is yours john doe i'm patching up the
neck wound hugging it down in the
abdomen
fast as positive internal bleeding yeah
no kidding i'm not having problems
ventilating okay let's prepare to aim
debate
last long what nothing it's just it's a
team sport i want to hear from you
ems reported that there was a propane
barbecue that the vehicle rammed into
causing any explosion i love the fact
that the doctor asked the nurse to speak
up
um because she was obviously being
nervous and hesitant it is a team sport
and i think hospital systems that
encourage that type of speaking up
actually give better patient care have
you ever felt a doctor perhaps not
allowing you to do that
all the time actually especially like
when we get like a new uh
set of residents they all kind of come
with a different mentality but they kind
of want to
show that they know what they're talking
about so they're going to give you all
different types of
differentials and stuff like that of
what could be happening or what could be
affecting this patient
however the nurse is the one typically
who has the experience to say
yes like i understand what you're
talking about but on from a nurse's
mindset
set especially in a trauma situation a
lot of us have what's called like a tnc
certification which is a trauma
certification
we have a very specific algorithm that
we're going through and so in our heads
we're like
time is of the essence all right we need
the 18 gauge needles in both arms we
need to undress the patient do a full
body scan
and no one is allowing you to do your
job because they're trying to
get like electrolytes on the patient or
something that can be done later and
they're doing it out of order
excuse me doctor uh
nurse oh sorry i just assumed it's all
good
so i was near the sauron art institute i
saw the whole thing happen
i fainted right on the sidewalk were you
dehydrated i don't think so
have you had a cough recently no
any cardiovascular condition why is he
out of nowhere like
passing by in the hallway and then
questioning the patient i'm confused
this is funny too because like as soon
as she said she fainted i was like
they may think they're okay especially
when i started out on the ambulance you
have people who are kind of like in
shock
and they're walking around and they feel
fine because they have that adrenaline
pumping through their bodies but in
reality
whenever you know you're taking their
vitals and stuff like that they can have
very high heart rate very low blood
pressure
so they're showing signs of internal
bleeding but they may not be aware of it
when she said she fainted i would have
questioned her
a little bit more as well especially
once i saw that she was pregnant
yeah absolutely i think uh whenever
adrenaline's going you might not feel
certain symptoms
my issue with sort of how this happens
you know
it's very structured uh when you walk
into an emergency room at least where
i've been
where they have a nurse assigned to a
specific group of patients
so that if someone's just passing in the
hallway and someone says hey by the way
i passed out
the answer would not be okay what's
going on even though that's the correct
line of questioning
it would be okay let me get your nurse
or let me get your doctor we can have
that conversation established
because if everyone just kind of
strolled the hallways and started
questioning patients
patients would end up getting frustrated
because they continuously have to
repeat the story and when they do that
they feel less inclined to give the same
amount of details each time
last long is going to make the
anesthetized job real tricky yeah if he
makes it to the or
there's no typo negative i mean we could
push hydroxyethyl starch but
why do they not have oh blood and they
seem like they're in a very large city
as well so they should have this
it's a level one trauma center like what
are you doing i'm a negative universal
donor we can buy him some time
hook me up to him are you serious we'll
do a whole blood transfusion
they do it on the battlefield that's
pretty much what we're looking at here
okay chances are he'll react negatively
chances are he's gonna die
i have never seen that happen nor do i
think that's ethical
nor do i think that should ever be
happening i mean like have you
seen anything even remotely like that
happen no no
no no no no no no no no no no no like
that could never
happen god forbid what if he had
something
that this patient could contract from
him he may not even be aware of it you
know what i mean like you could possibly
do more harm than good
is there something wrong could you shift
just a little to your left please
please tell me what's wrong i am
i can't find the heartbeat what i i need
some help here while it's important to
figure out what's going on
on the ultrasound it's more important to
make sure that the patient is
comfortable
in understanding the process that's
going on i believe that he's quite new
so for him to be using this ultrasound
as well especially not with anybody
watching him
of course this is a crisis situation so
i have to give them the benefit of the
doubt
however with his hand shaking and what
he's doing he's saying that i can't find
the heartbeat he doesn't
seem like he's very well equipped to be
handling this ultrasound nor is he like
possibly checked off or certified to use
his ultrasound
i just bumped my head uh please go take
care of my students a cute head drama
is a priority we have blue like
berendisia autoria
she has to rule out rhinorrhea and
odoria
i feel like like nasal discharge is she
just rattling off medical vocabulary
please just uh go take care of my
students i will right after i give you a
full narrow workup
but in order to do that
i'm gonna need a bad night be right back
nurse uh
if you see my um my um for
frank just see me we need help
i would have liked to see the doctor
instead of rush to use the pen light
to actually check a pulse and see if the
patient is not
going to cardiac arrest he should have
been triaged we should have had a set of
vitals
his pupils should have been checked all
these things should have been checked
having
uh different sized pupils also known as
anisocoria
is a sign that there is some sort of
neurological defect happening the steps
that are taken
are valid it's just the order of the
steps seems off you're welcome to assist
in the o.r
no uh they need me on the floor thanks
i'll page you when he's in recovery
take care of him we'll do our best are
they really in the or without facebook
yeah so i was like
they are who are you
i'm nazn i'm you nice scrubs
do they come in your size
mr richie he's just out of surgery where
should i leave him you shouldn't
come down two nurses to a sean mendes
concert
and now this we have a video where you
talk about
quote-unquote nurses eating their young
is that what you feel is happening here
first off i'm not sure if she was a
nurse or if she was like the unit
secretary but
uh i can definitely tell that this girl
gnaws
this this nurse she has what i feel is a
romanticized version of
what her first day is gonna be and how
it is gonna be a nurse that i'm gonna
come in here and i'm gonna take charge
she's gonna learn really quick that like
you're not gonna walk in here
and find your patient like on page five
of your textbook you should know nathan
suffered a subarachnoid hemorrhage
there's still significant swelling we
are hoping that that subsides
and what if it doesn't the damage
will be irreparable but there's still
hope that's a tough situation especially
in trauma where you have mass casualties
and i understand that they're kind of
like in a crisis situation however
i do not think that was her place to
explain
that at that moment she should have had
the care team she should have had a
discussion with the doctor
and the doctor should have explained
that uh to the family member and the
doctor would have been there to
answer any questions that she would have
had also you know they mentioned the
subarachnoid hemorrhage
usually that presents with a really bad
like worst in your life headache
he did not have a headache so that was
really unusual from
a medical perspective i will say that
there are many times where
another part of the healthcare team will
start explaining things to a patient
prematurely and sometimes inaccurately
where
i have to go in and then debrief the
patient on what they've already been
told
and what they already know and then sort
of put the things back into their
correct place
it's a tough scenario where you want
everyone to speak up and educate
but at the same time you want to just
make sure that it's done accurately
arjundo is the driver who did this they
saw him trying to save him yeah
they got it wrong i was just in there
holding his hand comforting him when he
told me it was him
linda call security he's alive because
of us grace
we didn't know okay if you did know
would that have changed your management
our job is not to play judge or jury
our job is to focus on one thing and one
thing only that's helping
patients irrespective of their criminal
status
race their ethnicity whether they're
nice they're mean or
anything like that at the end of the day
your job is to save lives in the best
way
possible regardless of her feelings
towards the situation
um she doesn't need to notify the police
and she does need to get security
involved that way
this patient does not end up harming
other people
but yeah it should not have changed the
way that she rendered care at all and
bianca
how common is it for folks who have
traumatic brain injury to say wacky
things that are not extremely
extremely common lydia i'm dr banks i'm
going to be delivering your baby today
wow that sounds so surreal hi um the
noob we couldn't find the heartbeat
yeah you're already a bit of a legend
around here
one of my biggest gripes in medicine is
that conversation could have happened
away from the patient that should not
have said yes in front of the patient
because one it undermines the nurse and
it affects the trust that the patient
has in that nurse
and it also affects the way that the
patient you know sees the doctor
that should have been something that was
discussed uh behind closed doors the
only time i will give
the benefit of the doubt in this
situation is if it's in the midst of an
emergency or trauma and you have to make
a correction in that moment
this is not one of those instances
nice try mr tippett
why is she calling a code blue uh in my
hospital code blue is a person who is
pulseless
we don't call code blues because i am
essentially a part of the code blue team
so i would have been there and we would
have had the staff to have handled the
situation anyways
everything is a code blueprint er this
one's from seven years ago
i knew it what
no one ever changes their emergency
contact oh
no no no no no
[Music]
this is sarah talk at the beep sarah
hi um
i'm calling from saint mary's
lydia's in the hospital hipaa alert
hipaa breakage alert
yeah is a thing especially with nurses
being at the bedside so often
they get attached and you have to be
very careful you have to be careful with
the personal information that you give
but you also have to understand
his patient was coherent okay at this
point if that patient wanted to call
lydia whoever the emergency contact was
she had every right to do so
patient information is a protected asset
rightly so
everyone's entitled to their own
confidential health care record
and the fact that he just thought it's
the right thing to do
even if it works out it's the wrong
thing to do and it's potentially
a reason why someone could get fired my
name is wolf i'm i'm a nurse here and
i've actually been looking for you all
day don't tell me
you have my fingers actually
oh oh wow i was just joking
but due to the length of time that
they've been separated from your
hand their toast
that wouldn't be his call to make
because there could be viable tissue
there
there could be tissue that can be cut
off and the rest of the finger can be
reattached there's a lot of options here
that i wouldn't even feel comfortable
making as a doctor as a family medicine
doctor
i would only be comfortable if a hand
dedicated hand plastic surgeon
would say that mrs ritchie we've been
closely monitoring nathan as his
ventilator support was removed while we
conducted an apnea test
unfortunately his test results are
positive
what does that mean a positive result is
defined by the total absence of
respiratory efforts
it means nathan has no brain activity
that call would never be made within 24
hours of the accident
you would wait for inflammation to
subside for the patient's
blood levels to return to normal
electrolytes to
return to normal and only after a
designated period of time of doing these
tests repeatedly could you even come
close to making a recommendation like
this i mean i think you got out of
surgery a couple hours ago like
how can you possibly know that
anesthesia could be wearing
seriously now i'm 100 there with you too
like this is literally like the same day
this is happening this is no
in no way can you call something this
quickly especially with inflammation and
everything like you're
you're talking about yeah and the
neurological uh system
is notorious for recovering slowly
[Music]
for anybody who's wondering why they're
lined outside of the or they're honoring
the patient
for uh his organs so that he will go on
to save more lives
any thoughts on the show bianca what do
you think accuracy one to ten
i'm low i'm sitting at a four i want to
say more of like a five out of a ten
yeah i feel like this is one of the
shows that i've seen that
goes kind of above and beyond to show
nurses in their capacity however
i feel like it's always like they'll
show you nurses but then they they show
too little of doctors like it's very
hard to find a show that shows the
proper dynamics between them well i hope
you enjoyed bianca and i
watching the first episode of nurses we
actually also played a game of would you
rather
check it out here click on it as always
stay happy and healthy
you